make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob uh and
this video is gonna be a tough one
because on one part i'm happy that we're
killing cyborg the downside is he's kind
of hard to kill i kind of prefer it
would be easier because dude i like
making fun of cyborg alright i'm sorry
i'm just gonna say it i like making fun
of cyborg the only people who are fans
of cyborg are people who watch the
original teen titans show those are the
only people who are fans of cyborg
nobody else cares
but nobody else likes cyborg but before
we get into what makes him so hard to
kill we're going to take a look at his
origin
so cyborg was created by marv wolfman
and george perez and first appeared in
dc
comics presents number 26 in 1980. now
two scientists by the name of silas and
eleanor stone were researching
artificial enhancements to human
intelligence and used their son victor
as a test subject which makes perfect
sense
right certainly something a parent would
do in this day and age and i'm not even
joking
as a result victor's iq is greatly
enhanced but his relationship with his
parents
is strained and so when visiting their
lab victor sees a gelatinous creature
emerging from an interdimensional
gateway that his mother was working on
and ultimately kill her now the creature
severely injures vic
as well but his father is able to send
the creature back through the portal
before it killed him and so mortally
wounded victor eventually wakes to
discover that his father had outfitted
him with various prosthetics and
implants initially enraged at what his
father had done he eventually comes to
accept it and goes on to join the teen
titans now when dc comics
launched the new 52 they made some
significant changes to cyborg's origin
in this version
vic is a high school football student
who stands out who also has a tenuous
relationship with his father
a scientist at star labs and when his
father misses yet another one of his
football games victor goes to confront
his father at his lab where he's working
on a mother box a piece of fourth world
technology used by the new gods now
mother boxes are basically super
computers that can perform a variety of
functions such as energy manipulation
healing and teleportation through
summoning boom tubes which also allow
for interstellar travel but regardless
the mother box explodes killing nearly
everybody in the room and gravely
injuring victor now similar to his first
origin story
vic's father saves him through the use
of technology outfitting him with
cybernetic parts and injecting him with
nanites
but victor is also drastically changed
by the energy emitted by the motherbox
which now becomes part of his physiology
and so instead of him going on to join
the teen titans in this continuity
victor is actually a founding member of
the justice league something teen titans
fans were pissed about now as for his
powers the cybernetic parts that make up
much of cyborg's body provide him
with superhuman strength speed stamina
and durability the computer system that
exists within him
also allows him to communicate with
other computers and also grants him a
variety of other abilities
for instance his artificial eye grants
him superhuman vision and he can store a
variety of weapons including lasers a
grappling hook and a sound cannon that
incapacitates enemies and is powerful
enough to shatter stone but due to the
nature of technology
cyborg is able to upgrade his powers as
he discovers new ways to augment them
the motherbox technology that exists
within cyborg also grants him several
abilities such as the ability to produce
powerful emp blasts to summon boom tubes
which allow him to travel anywhere in
the universe instantaneously and find
some measure of a way to stay relevant
in comic books on top of that
cyborg's iq has been measured at 170
meaning he possesses a genius level
intellect but not enough since to
realize that the justice league keeps
him around because somebody has to guard
the watchtower but with that in mind how
do we go about killing cyborg well i
think the first thing that we have to do
is find a way to neutralize the
motherbox technology that exists within
him now as long as he's able to generate
boom tubes
cyborg will be able to disappear
instantaneously and wind up literally
anywhere in the universe and so how can
we do that well mother boxes
never run out of energy so we can't try
any sort of energy siphoning because
they'll simply just siphon more energy
from the source which is a limitless
reserve of energy that's never exhausted
mother boxes can be destroyed however
we're not really dealing with a physical
mother box here but energy from the
mother box that has been incorporated
into the technology
running throughout cyborg's body at any
rate even if they are destroyed they can
typically be regenerated but there is
one exception to this
as it turns out mother boxes cannot
function if their users
lack the spiritual integrity to wield it
for instance when orion one of the new
gods was infected with the anti-life
equation his mother box
ceased to function and i think that
gives us a pretty good idea
of what we will need to do to sever
cyborg's connection to his mother box
taking away not only his ability to use
boom tubes but denying him access to a
multitude of powers the fourth world
technology grants him what we're going
to have to do here
is infect cyborg with the anti-life
equation and hope the events of dc's
don't take place where he basically
kills the world now while this sounds
simple enough
in theory it's going to be incredibly
difficult in practice the anti-life
equation
has been doggedly sought out by darkseid
for centuries so it's not like we can
just readily access it but hey that's
why i said cyborg was more difficult to
kill than people realize
if it was easy it wouldn't make for a
very interesting video but our task
isn't just over by infecting cyborg with
the anti-life equation
although his connection to the mother
box is severed he still has the
cybernetic enhancements to his body that
we need to deal with
as they still grant him a variety of
abilities he'll still have greatly
enhanced strength and durability that
we'll have to deal with as well as the
bevy of offensive weapons that we
mentioned earlier
and most worrisome is his ability to
interface with pretty much any
technology that he wants to
and so that opens up a lot more
possibilities for him to either surveil
us or avoid our attacks
or to take us out before we attack him i
mean just to give me perspective
he could literally just communicate with
all the computers controlling some
tomahawk missiles and launch them all at
us which would make killing him
impossible
since we'd be dead and so our next step
has to be to take out cyborg's
technological enhancements and to do
that
i think we have a few options such as
infecting him with some sort of computer
virus or maybe generating an
electromagnetic pulse to shut down his
cybernetic component
if we take those components out vic is
then going to have
a lot of extra weight to drag around and
taking him out becomes a lot easier but
failing any of that
another way we get the job done is
actually to the use of a psychic attack
the cybernetic implants to cyborg
are a source of strength but they can
also be his weakness as he has had
trouble in the past with retaining his
humanity as he's always felt like he's
more machine
than man and so if we're able to
effectively shut off his mind the
technological parts of cyborg will have
a free reign to overtake the human side
of him and vic would effectively be no
more while this technically accomplishes
our mission
at the end we're still going to be left
with an artificially intelligent robot
with vast powers to deal with so i don't
really think this is an ideal plan for
us to go down but yeah like i said guys
killing cyborg
is deceptively difficult right but if
you guys have any better ideas leave
them down in the comments section
because i'm curious to see what you guys
come
up with with that being said we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so